good day everyone welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia please allow me to welcome you
to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture is supported
by the
uva integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and by a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr
james morris from the university of
virginia dr morris serves as an
associate professor of psychology and is
director of the graduate admissions
program
here at the uva psychology department
work in his laboratory is focused on how
the interactions thoughts and beliefs
and feelings of others are represented
in the brain
processes collectively referred to as
social perception
techniques employed in the laboratory
include functional magnetic resonance
imaging event related potential
recordings
and molecular genetics techniques most
of the work is concerned with building
basic neurobiological models of social
function
but also explore the neural basis of
social deficits associated
with autism spectrum disorder additional
work seems to
seeks to examine how individual
difference in social perception
may be related to epigenetic mechanisms
two broad projects currently going on in
dr morris's social neuroscience lab
involve a longitudinal investigation of
the neural development
in preschool children as well as a
project in healthy adults aimed at
identifying variability in neural
systems
that is predictive of differences in
social capacity
finally in order to appropriately
consider the promise of brain mapping
techniques and drawing conclusions about
individual differences
dr morris and his laboratory seek to
identify new approaches
which move from simple associations to
predictive frameworks
allowing for better causal inferences
and less false positive findings
dr morris's lecture today is entitled
functional imaging of individual
differences in social cognition
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube
if you're watching via youtube thank you
so much for joining us and also
our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit questions for
dr morris via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome jamie we are so
excited to hear from you today
thank you um i appreciate the
introduction and
um i'm happy to tell you a little bit
about the work in
in my lab um kind of made this somewhat
uh general in terms of uh some of the
bigger themes that have gone on and some
of the directions we're moving in
that i think address some of the more
important topics uh going forward when
considering
individual differences in social
cognition uh social perception
and particularly with the use of
neuroscience methods to look at these
factors um i've been using this slide
for years it's still relevant it gives a
little bit of like a little postcard
of uh psychologically what i'm
interested in um
i am in the department of psychology i
am a psychologist by training
so i do have an interest in one sort of
domain area
although the work becomes pretty broad
fairly quickly
when i talk about what i'm interested in
in terms of my domain of research
i talk about this idea of social
perception which isn't
uh sort of a concrete definition it's
really sort of a catch-all
for a number of skills that fall under
an umbrella and you can think of it
as a set of skills uh centered around
our ability to identify other social
entities
and to make inferences about the
dispositions
actions goals and intentions of others
these are things that humans reflexively
do
they follow a pretty strict
developmental course as as children are
growing up
and they're important for the way that
we build social relationships for the
way that we
build teams or the way that we build
close relationships romantic
relationships uh they
help us in terms of promoting social
proximity
and allows us to essentially get to know
one another
and to uh get to understand one another
which allows for deeper sort of
connection
in this connection obviously is
important from a nourishment and health
standpoint
um and it really sort of colors uh what
it means to be human in a number of ways
uh but i look at the very basic uh
portions of this
uh again going back to things such as
identity so how
do we understand um uh who people are
based off of facial characteristics
uh people we've met versus people we
haven't um and then how do we take
simple cues
such as gays cues or simple biological
motion
cues to to understand what other people
are doing and what they're thinking
um and and these are things that we're
really good at um but they are also
things that uh deficits exist in our
population and deficits are often
associated with
social and emotional sort of
disorders so developmental disorders and
psychiatric disorders so
there's a lot of importance that gets
placed through them
now um in order to sort of take you
through
the way that i've come to understand
this and the way that i've come to
understand the neuroscience of this
i'll take you through the way that the
field has come to
understand uh social perception and the
way that we
have relied on the technologies of the
time and the way that we have then used
these technologies to make
our inferences and the goals of our
particular studies
now what you have uh with fmri so fmri
obviously is a technique that has been
dominant in cognitive neuroscience
research
since about the late 90s the earliest
studies were done in the early 90s
but you know in terms of actually
getting a a critical mass of literature
you started to see
a big uptick in the late 90s into the
early 2000s
into now where it's very it's ubiquitous
it's all around
new publications every day obviously
some
some real sort of core areas etc one of
the things that
was a technique that you would see very
early in fmri research is
what i would call studies of category
specificity and this is really
specificity with regards to the visual
system
so you can think of the visual system
you can think of really
basic things like gradients and
checkerboards and how primary visual
cortex is
very dedicated to certain visual stimuli
which is very true when you get into
primary visual cortex when you get into
the secondary visual cortices
you start to see specialization for more
complex visual items
and you can see some level of patterning
or category specificity fmri studies
have established that there are certain
patterns that
you can associate with certain stimulus
classes for instance
faces so in 1997 uh nancy kamlisher used
this term fusiform face area to describe
uh some of her work and some of the
other work most notably coming from
places like greg mccarthy's lab
looking at uh the pattern of response in
this fusiform gyrus area
when looking at faces compared to other
stimulus classes
for instance things like letter strings
which also show a clustering of activity
in most
most people's brains um also during this
time later
a couple years later you would see
reports of things like uh places which
again uh
work out a canvasser's lab what they
would do is they'd functionally
characterize the response
and then use a a name so that they can
go back and test these these areas later
in this case it's called the paragraph
cable place area
even to the lateral surface here where
people had described
um uh activity towards these headless
bodies
which i could give a different talk
about what we think is going on here
but essentially just that there are some
areas too that
seem to have uh odd sort of
characteristics in terms of the
preference for
uh response in terms of how strong they
respond to different visual
classes of information and then finally
one that i've worked on a lot
biological motion perception uh kevin
pelfrey who's a professor here at uva
now
um an expert in neurobiology of autism
spectrum disorders also did a lot of
the seminal work and fmri with
biological motion perception
uh and he did a lot of work here and i
did some work with him as well and
in my training on uh biological motion
characteristics in the superior temple
sulcus area
and essentially what we mean by this is
this is an area that unlike
general coordinated motion which tends
to be carried out and processed back in
more
primary visual cortex this is a
secondary more of association type of
cortex that seems to be
activated more by biological motion so
motion made by
um humans in terms of point light
walkers or other sorts of
animations that we can see okay now
i want to actually go backwards in time
a lot of the work that
we had noticed from early fmri work
really came out of other domains
one domain would be eeg
which is uh a uh electro encephalography
um or erp type of work event related
potential work
and that's often from the scalp but we
also
under rare conditions have chances to
record directly from the human brain
and work by my former mentor greg
mccarthy
uh true at allison the spencers at yale
and then other groups around the country
uh we're looking at individuals with uh
epilepsy people that were
had intractable epilepsy and they were
being monitored for seizures as a way
that they could potentially intervene
and while they were being monitored for
these seizures you could
record directly from the surface of the
brain so what
greg and others were doing at the time
is actually greg was interested
at those times in language and one of
the things that they were looking at is
letter string processing across the
cortex and in the fusiform
and during that time they had found so
much responsiveness to faces when using
other classes of data
that greg really started publishing a
lot on that i'm bringing this up because
you're going to see some things that
lead to a little bit of
conflicting results when considering
fmri versus considering
eeg these are data i actually collected
in the one
year that i was doing intracranial
recordings uh which was now
14 years ago so these are quite old uh
but the data
you know they're nice they make an
interesting point uh one is is that you
can find
uh various levels of specificity across
the cortex here you can see
this electrodes down here showing these
phase specific responses one here is the
c5 electrode
which is right here a1 electrode
wherever i pop that sucker right here
is actually showing a letter letter
specific response there
and you can see this in this early 200
microvolt potential
along the cortex of the brain
and again here uh this is from a
different patient now you can take a
different sort of
screening task and here you have animals
um you have
uh fourier transform just scrambled
images to see if there's any kind of
visual consistency in there
you have faces uh fruits tools and again
letter strings
this would be what we consider a phase
specific response this n5 electrode here
you can see a big response here
in this j2 big response here to faces
but not the other stimulus types here
and again it's not exactly one spot
there are
sort of patchy organization where there
seems to be some specialization for this
closer into the occipital area
and again up here in the medial temporal
area as well
um functional localizers in fmri work
are mostly concerned with identifying
this type of activity in the same way we
might identify it
with it in this intracranial eeg
and then applying sort of a convenient
heuristic that allows for comparison so
by
calling something to fusiform face area
i can then go forward and say
okay now i have a map and then i can map
it on each individual subject
and then i can test the specific
properties of it i can test what the
impact of attention is on it i can test
the impact of affect maybe facial
expression
and things like that so it's useful in
that way one of the negatives or
drawbacks of it is that sometimes people
think that it would reify
function simplify sometimes complex
brain functions to say
something like processing of a face is
all carried out in one area which is not
the intention
and uh just a note there at the end is
just because you find activation for a
particular class of a visual stimulus
doesn't mean you found the st the center
of a complex function
and this is something that you know
causes great argument for people that
were both in fields
that looked at neuroimaging as being
sort too reductionistic
and people outside of uh fmri as well so
you have this sort of back and forth
between uh this really
strong desire to be able to map what is
uh
a system of uh functional specialization
without
trying to boil it down to an
oversimplification so there's always
been a little bit of a tension between
the two
now what i want to show you from data
that i had collected
what you would typically see in an fmri
study which i said
gets to be a little paradoxical or maybe
a little conflicting at times
so here you have results of a general
localizer analysis in this case i was
showing faces flowers and headless
bodies
now i want to show you first this this
results when you look at the group level
of faces versus flowers which here you
can see in the triangle
you get this strong activation face is
greater than flowers
it's stronger on the right side than the
left side which is something that we've
seen with face perception over time
um and then medial to that you'll see
flowers being active
uh stronger than faces this is a classic
result that i could probably get in any
number of subjects
very simply just by putting them in the
magnet and we can demonstrate this if we
were doing a simple experiment for
students in the class i'd probably do
something like this
now when you actually look though and
you use these headless bodies
and then you use those as a stimulus
class you find
again this sort of lateral body is
greater than flower
medial you don't get as much difference
between the flower and the body as you
did before with the face
and so it sort of leads you to wondering
what's the difference the processing
demand differences
for this unique stimulus class and then
the final part of that that i want to
make this point on this is
here when you compare faces versus
bodies now you no longer have this
specialization
so this area that you might call the
fusiform face area
when using this second class of stimulus
a body without a face
no longer comes out in this group-based
analysis
and then medial to that you actually do
have activation again it looks like the
body is maybe being treated as both
object
and face there's different ideas as to
what that meant
uh so some people speculated that maybe
there was a contextual filling in of
information
and others said you know well maybe
there's also body specific responses and
that fmri isn't resolving it in a
spatial way right next to there
go back to the intracranial data now and
again as i showed you before
you have this faces versus flowers so
the same thing
same basic experiment but recording
straight from the source of the fusiform
in this case
here you have this face response and
then you have this flower response and
you get almost nothing to a flower you
get this really nice
n200 to faces now you throw in this body
this headless body and again this is
flat so the same thing that i showed you
in fmri where these two stimuli seem to
be equivalent in the bold response
is clearly showing a distinguishable
difference on this area of the fusiform
at 200 milliseconds
and again here you have faces versus
flowers in this occipital type of
electrode
you throw in a body and again the body
stimulus looks very much
like the flower stimulus here again
great functional specialization for a
face response at 200 milliseconds
um again here's the um i think i showed
you that before okay yeah those are just
repeating sorry and here's another
electrode here just showing the same
exact thing
so again i can show you a couple of
these but these are all coming from
different patients
but the pattern remains the same we can
find
functional specialization for faces in
the fusiform at 200 milliseconds
and we can resolve this in ways that
we're not easily resolving
with the fmri signal now you
sometimes when you study the brain you
hear about complementary
sort of uh techniques
um one being high in spatial resolution
meaning fmri the other being high in
temporal resolution
uh erps coming from the scalp um
erp eeg and erps coming from the surface
of the brain or high in both obviously
but it's very rare that we can do it
because we're looking at people that are
in for neurosurgery so it's only a very
tiny small subset of the population
but to sort of sum up what i'm getting
at here you have this
n200 component which is showing little
or no habituation
to repeated faces so what we've done
over time is we've tested properties of
it
and you can show that this early end 200
that is doing a nice job distinguishing
is pretty much insensitive to almost
every psychological manipulation you'll
throw at it
whereas these fusiform activations are
pretty much influenced by every
psychological
uh manipulation you throw at it so you
can
manipulate the attentive qualities you
can change the affect
uh you can change the emotional context
you can do all kinds of tricks with
things that are task relevant or task
irrelevant priming learning
lots of things seem to change this
response here
very little changes the response here so
in general the nature of the measurement
is different
and the inferences you're supposed you
could really be making about this need
to be limited by this um and it
speaks to the idea that this this again
is not necessarily a center of face
processing
uh that uh is capturing all the various
domains of what we do with faces
okay i already said that all right so
um face perceptions is something that i
have
uh sort of started to look at back way
back when and i've been thinking about
it a lot again lately
um i'm bringing this up and i'm kind of
going through this long introduction to
get back to
um a point that i i'd like to make which
is that
uh face perception and face memory
itself is a really old problem in
cognitive psychology and cognitive
neuroscience
we have a lot of work outside of the
domain of neuroscience
where we have looked at how people
remember
faces people's perception of faces we
can interrupt people's perception of
faces by inverting them
people study things such as the other
race or the other age effect the
tendency to remember
uh people's faces that are are more like
those that uh
are in the environment in which we grew
up or developed in
um and so there's just a lot of work in
this domain and
and we also understand from the context
of neuropsychological work
uh that there's disorders where people
have trouble with faces prosopagnosics
don't recognize familiar faces
uh people with autism uh have some um
interesting sometimes
deficits in both face detection and face
recognition
and it's become a big work in cognitive
neuroscience because of the
specialization
it's been one of the most concentrated
on in terms of functional localizers and
category specificity
in the ways that i described before okay
so but here's the problem
even if we can reasonably quantify a
neural signature of face perception
does that tell us anything about how
well one remembers faces
right so even if we could find something
that we would agree upon
a biomarker this is the
uh activity that we're going to look at
for when someone is viewing a face
and even if we can agree upon what the
principles of that are which i said
would be hard anyway because
it depends on how you're measuring it
with what tool you're measuring with it
even if we can do that does that tell us
anything about how well
remember we're eating lunch
sorry i'm trying to mute people okay uh
so uh even if we can do that so
the interesting thing about face
recognition is is that when they
when they first started describing
deficits in it
people thought you know well you either
recognize faces or you don't
we do have documented cases of damage
where
uh there are individuals that have
deficit clear deficit that's associated
with damage
and then when they started looking even
further there's also people that have
clear deficits with no
uh damage or no known damage and
we call these people developmental
prostagnosics they
try they struggle with faces uh
really a lot with the advents of the
internet uh researchers like brad
duchene is at harvard are at dartmouth
now um
a lot of people have looked at face
recognition across the population
and it varies most people
expert you can definitely say because
faces are something that we do
great recognition with but there are
some people that are better than others
and there are some people that are
really bad at it there are people that
have deficits and
prosopagnosics and then on the other
side of that there are people that are
excellent at it they're exceptional
they're called super recognizers
they're rare again they represent a tiny
little portion of the tail
of the population but they recognize all
faces they've encountered it's
it's kind of uh it's intriguing how well
they are
how good they are at it so it is a
spectrum of of a capability
um when they've taken this apart further
looking at this in twin studies twin
studies
are a good way of looking at the genetic
component of a skill
so here in monozygotic twins uh you can
see
twin one twin two performance on face
recognition highly correlated
point seven so um clearly
a argument for that face recognition
biological and genetic heritable in this
case
uh dizygotic twins on the other hand uh
they do show a
significant association 0.9 is not
trivial in this case
but they are not they don't share the
same exact genes as their twins do
and it's less so you can make this
really strong argument
that base recognition itself is
heritable
okay so um sorry let me move on here
so given that let me go back to that a
second and just get my point across so
given this
we have a behavior that we know is
variable in the population
we have strong evidence
for biological uh genetic
input that should explain some of these
differences and and the differences
themselves are likely stable
and they so a pretty good degree of
stability to my knowledge
when we tested it across time so all
that
said we still can't do a very good job
of collecting neuroimaging data and
explaining this variability if i just
collected people in the magnet took all
their activity in their fusiform face
area
predicted how well they would do on this
task the results would not be
terrific they might they might be
significant but the effect size would
not be great
so there's a couple of problems there
and these problems have been
highlighted uh in recent criticisms
of neuroimaging work in general uh this
summer there was a lot of action on
twitter that i saw
uh which keeps the same flavor of every
couple of years people start in on this
which is that
fmri for all of its terrific utility in
terms of mapping the brain at a group
level
has not led to reliable biomarkers for
disease or disorder
to the extent to which we can count on
them
for telling us much about health in uh
ways of designing interventions
ways of using diagnostics so we still
have a long way to go
in fact a lot of the um argument about
it is pretty grave in terms of the way
they talk about it is it's just a
failure
but our argument is a little different
it's that
there's there's a couple problems here
one is is the way in which we
encountered these types of uh problems
to begin with
when fmri first began we were interested
in inference at group levels we were
interested in brain maps on
average the way that we would use the
things like the general linear model
was meant to reduce variance and find
congruence across participants
not to uh highlight where the
differences are
and then look at those differences
themselves at the same time
we also had big super loud machines that
are uncomfortable to sit in
and sometimes crappy stimulus
presentation devices and things like
that
and our tasks weren't great so one thing
that drives
psychologists nuts is when you look at
tasks that have no reliability
and then you're trying to use these
tasks as stable markers of difference
so a lot of the tasks that we've grown
accustomed to
in mri research are not psychometrically
solid in this case
so in a study that we're doing in my lab
right now
is aimed at a potential solution to this
problem
on two sides one is improved behavioral
tasks so this is uh my student andrew
graves up in the
corner there he is working with a couple
another student in cognitive area uh
jesse gradman as well as
working with some of our quantitative
faculty
on a technique here this is exploratory
graph analysis which has been developed
by hudson galino
which is helps to essentially
uh create tasks he's they're working to
create a task
that is matched in structure and
performance
so a face recognition test that's short
enough to be in the magnet
it can be matched in uh structure and
performance uh both with
the non-face stimulus and the face
stimulus the faces and control stimuli
have to have a high similar split half
reliability so their performance across
the tasks need to be
reliable they need to be short and they
need to be able to
be able to have a face and a non-face
feature
that have a different ability so that
you have ability to
to engage the different systems so that
you can have a dissociable
memory task from the for the faces
versus the non-phased stimuli
and this is something that you can get
with things like exploratory
graph analysis in this case this is
something that we're doing on that end
on the other end we're getting away from
as i said was a problem this idea
of trying to quantify single regions
and then assuming that those regions
carry the variance that can explain the
individual differences
as we know this isn't a great way to
explain individual differences because
the ways that
these types of areas were defined to
begin with were often based off of areas
where
we find differences at a group level so
what we've
kind of moved to now as a field and i'll
have more on this in a second
is looking at the connections
connections across the brain
um so we're trying to find measures that
will be sensitive to individual
differences
and a lot of the uh of the promise has
come from
measures of the connectome itself so
here uh this is just showing you quickly
that
andrew has built a model that i'll tell
you a little bit more about how you go
about doing this
but essentially you can model the
connections across the connectome
you can distinguish individual subjects
from one another
and then you can look at variability
within these connections
and how well those very that variability
maps onto
a cognitive or a perceptual domain of
interest
so a lot of this and a lot of our
inspiration from this comes from
uh some of the reports like this one
here i think this is a particularly
seminal one by finn and colleagues
uh called functional connectome
fingerprinting
in this case uh what they've done is
they've taken data from the human
connectome project
and in this data set you have
participants that have participated
in resting state scans you have
participants that have taken part
in attention the tests of attention
attention uh tasks of social
uh perception tasks of emotion tasks of
self-control
generally an entire battery of things
that cognitive neuroscientists might be
interested in
and what they did is they had these six
imaging conditions over two days and
then there's two resting conditions
they took 126 subjects
they took the brain and they break it
out into 268 nodes
so you create 268 by 268
connectivity matrix so what you could do
then is you could take every one of
those nodes connected with every other
node so you just take a correlation of
them if you'd like to
um each element of the matrix matrix
represents an
edge so it's the connection strength
between the two nodes so
in graph theory of course to talk about
edges in this case and the strength of
those connections
and then what you can do is you take a
database matrix with the highest
correlation of edges with the target
selected
so what happens is for instance in a
rest run
rest two you take all the rest one scans
and you train
a classifier and then this gets used to
picking out where all the variability is
and it has something unique about each
one of those subjects and then
after doing that you can use that to
predict who's who
in six in rest two um so if you have
some degree of a fingerprint meaning
there's some uniqueness
about an individual's connectome then
machine learning in this case
should be able to pick up on it and
indeed it does so
rest one rest two success rate was at
92.9 percent so 93
accurate this this model was at
predicting
identity of the participants uh rest two
to rest one so you just do this opposite
train on one and then look at the other
set
was 94.4 we've done this with our own
work
so this is from uh the human connectome
project the fin work that i represent
here
our own work we looked at this in the
vcap participants
the vcap participants are a unique group
this is from the virginia cognitive
aging project
these are individuals that are 60 to 80
years old
we scan them as well they have a little
bit different scan procedures
they were scanned nine minutes apart
they did do a demanding attention task
in between the two
uh rest phases though so there probably
should be some difference uh
between them if we're gonna pick up on
it uh but again we see similar sort of
results in this case when we take rest
one the rest two we had ninety four
point five percent accuracy and rest two
the rest one we had ninety six point
seven
four percent accuracy and again this was
with 92 subjects
if you break this down further here's
what
it looks like when you look at a
connectome um they're they look messy
ish on screen they don't look like the
pretty blobs of cognitive neuroscience
work or for functional category
specificity uh what this shows you in
this case
uh this is a tool that finn and
colleagues used as well in their
original paper
which we found helpful for our paper for
our project here
we have this differential power measure
this differential power measure
indicates which one of these edges are
being used the most
to show unique variants so which one of
these edges are most informative
when picking out which person is which
when helping identify
the idea of each subject all right so
these are thought you can think of these
as being the most sort of variable
and indeed what they really found is the
strongest sort of connections that show
the most variability
uh that can be used in the model are
coming from um prefrontal areas this is
this this parental parietal here based
off of the atlas we used
but these prefrontal connections and
uh the prefrontal and parietal
connections um in general
uh both were very um indicative of
or they both had a lot of the
variability in it and they also showed
in a secondary analysis that uh they
were also the best at explaining a
cognitive variable like uh
intelligence and in the second
measure phi here these are connections
that are
uh very um uh ubiquitous across the
sample so they're
in everybody but they're not terribly
diagnostic in terms of separating
id from one another so they're
connections that you would find they're
stable connections
uh within subjects but they're not
highly variable across participants
and here you can see this is a lot of
within network stuff within visual
cortex and such
uh connectivity within the networks
themselves
and again here default mode very strong
across
left to right etc
okay so that's one potential solution
is better better stimulus better
analysis tools
another potential solution that we've
been using
is to think about ways that we can
maximize variability
so not only do we have the problem in
general category specific
functional neural imaging that we're
optimized for looking at areas
of congruence uh we're off also
oftentimes looking at healthy subjects
in my own work healthy adults 18 to 30
and processes of interest aren't
terribly variable in that case
yes people are different socially but
they also have all kinds of different
compensatory mechanisms and other things
that are at play
one thing that we can do is try to
capture the system
during known periods of time where these
functions
change and if we can do that that might
give us some insight
into the very various brain regions that
are changing over time
in the various brain regions that are
showing the most variability
uh this is just to show you a um a
figure that we've used um this is
actually from a grant itself
uh basically we've started from a
brain institute grant run by my student
amalia mcdonald to
assess a pediatric population and what
we're really
interested in this population is the
emergence of pro-social behaviors
at an interesting time as those kids
enter school as they go from young
children into
the early years of school and we're
interested in looking at
various measures that we can capture
from them including
fmri and including a lot of behavioral
testing
some of this stuff we do not have data
on there are things that are more
long-term ambitious goals
some of them we do have some data on
some early update on that i'll show you
in a little bit
uh so we have a long-standing sort of
project there
and one of our overarching hypotheses
in in this project is to look at the
role
of a candidate biological system uh
in this case it's the oxytocin system
and
the reason why we've done this is is
really for a couple of reasons one is is
that
we know the oxytocin system is very
important for the emergence of social
behaviors
um we know from work of my collaborator
jessica connolly
her students and postdocs and scientists
that
the developing human the way that they
interact with the environment
in the way that they develop in their
environment
has a lot of interactions with genetic
and other situational factors to
influence the development of the brain
and sort support the social perception
and we think that this is being
carried out with at least some role from
the oxytocin
system um some of our work over the
prior decade in adults
uh most notably a lot of work from uh
megan puglia here who's in the
department of neurology
uh at uva now and she worked in our labs
uh during the time we had run most of
these projects
looked at the role of the epigenetic
control of the oxytocin system
so the actions of oxytocin are mediated
by one receptor type the oxytocin
receptor gene
i'm not going to talk a lot about that
today i can give a whole talk on that
but essentially what you could do is you
can capture epigenetic variability in
this system
which governs the control of the
endogenous oxytocin system
and we can relate it to a lot of neural
endophenotypes
this was a figure from one of megan's
papers
alice and jack and other post doctors
now are another graduate student who's
now
faculty at george mason she did some of
the early work as well looking at some
of these measures too of
social perception and we have a series
of studies that have essentially looked
at
uh this uh system and the way that we
can uh represent uh uh epigenetic
variability
and how it plays out at the role at the
level of the brain this is jessica
connolly she's my primary collaborator
in this she's the one
that basically discovered uh the sites
along the oxytocin receptor that show
the most variability
they're the most diagnostic for
classifying
various differences social differences
and
also she has a complimentary program in
the prairie bowl
where they could actually manipulate
early social experience
and show the impact on social behaviors
themselves there's a lot of results that
come out of that work
too so again in this case we have a nice
candidate region
supported by one receptor type coded on
one gene
we have some inference uh that
it does impact variability and key brain
areas for social perception
and now we're trying to track it through
development um i won't talk about this
either but i'll put a key plug in there
again uh work that megan had done and
continues to do
now is is to try to track this very
early in life
in infants so we had a grant with the
nsf
uh to follow infants from four months of
age
and then follow them at three different
time points to understand how their
social environments
how their interaction with caregivers
impacts
the neural signatures that megan has
developed
such as neural entropy measures and how
this is related to differences
in oxytocin receptor methylation and how
oxytocin receptor methylation is
changing over time
and whether or not we can develop this
neuroepigenetic signature that predicts
behavior
and whether the signature can be used as
an early marker of dysfunction
which is ongoing work that megan is
working on uh with
collaborators in the medical school now
are you guys ready oh sorry let me go on
from there
okay so a couple of of issues that come
up here and how we're solving them
currently
and this is more related to going back
to as the kids get a little bit older
with developmental pediatric populations
but does impact infants as well
uh one of the things that we have some
issue with is is
one is is that we need reliable
biological markers and measurements
a lot of the early epigenetic work was
done with blood children don't like
getting their blood drawn we can't ask
parents to do it we won't get any
volunteers
so we've been able to develop saliva
assays as well this is quite an old
slide now i just pulled it earlier and i
didn't have the
updated one there's hundreds and
hundreds of people uh megan's tested a
lot of this
amalia has tested a lot of this uh katie
cruel postdoc
and justice lab has done a lot of work
on this in general our saliva assays
work which helps for this type of
these types of procedures another
problem is that children have trouble
staying still this is an issue with
functional neural imaging
and this is a really big issue with
connectome studies one of the things you
find in connectome studies is that
one of the biggest predictors of
connectome
effects is head movement so there's a
lot of spurious results that come out of
head movement
and particularly if you start getting
into developmental
disorder populations this could really
become a compound because
degree of of
impact in terms of the degree of deficit
might also really positively correlate
with someone's ability to even keep
their head still
which can create some issues this is an
image of a brain from a kid moving
their head this was actually my son
moving his head
looks like a picture where someone
doesn't stay still because that's
exactly what it is
and it causes big time problems with
with connectivity studies
uh what we've done to remedy this is
we've uh we've developed a
mock scanning protocol uh this is from
uh
our old mock scanning environment uh but
we do have a newer one over at fontaine
now
same system just a different room there
you make it a nice warm welcoming
environment as
molly has done here and you get the kids
to
learn to stay still in the fmri mri
environment
you play them movies you teach them to
play games where they keep their head
still and they can keep their head
within
you know a little small box it just
teaches them to be able to stay still
while you're playing magnet sounds and
you're basically simulating the
environment as best as possible
this head coil is the same it's it's not
the same because there's nothing in it
that is technological it's just plastic
but it has the same specifications in
terms of size and fit
as the head coil that we when we use
when we actually do imaging itself
this is a figure this is an older figure
as well uh amalia has done this on
close to 80 kids now and
this is just to show you that having an
effective mock scanning
procedure can really lead to you having
really great results with head motion
kids that are taking part in various
tasks this is a functional task this is
a task where they're actually
asked to watch various video types that
we've made
of of animate displays this is from
inscapes which is a
technique that's been developed by
another group which is
basically just to looks like 90 screen
savers to me but it's just to put
something on the screen when you're
collecting resting data
so that um you theoretically stay more
calm and you have something to do
something to watch in that case
but there's not any kind of real
psychological content to it that would
be that engaging
another thing that we do that i will
talk about briefly in a minute is we've
run free viewing paradigms where kids
are watching movies
uh kids aren't great at doing
psychological tasks all the time because
they find them boring and they don't
care that we
need good results so one of the things
they are good at is watching movies
though
um and so they they're entertained by
watching something like finding nemo
um in this case we can have them watch
these videos and then we can use
some analytical techniques that can go
about looking at various uh
brain networks while they're watching
these videos and differentiate the
content types
one of these techniques that we've been
using is something called inner subject
synchronization
uh intersubject correlation it's gets a
couple different names
it's really a technique that goes back
to
2004 2005 yuri hassan who's a
professor at princeton uh rafi uh our
dr malik there also was uh involved in
this type of work and what they had done
is they they took um participants
and they put them in the scanner and
they had them uh watch the movie
uh the good the bad the ugly all right
and
uh what what that did for them is is
that uh they had this this movie with
really rich content that's an old clint
eastwood uh western movie for people
that haven't seen it
it has a lot of scenes has a lot of
faces has a lot of changing dynamics to
it
and at this time you know no one had
done anything like it but what they were
able to do is they just took every
subject's voxels across their brain and
did a bunch of pairwise correlations
and they showed something that probably
shouldn't be all that hard to believe
which is that um people's brains look
remarkably similar when they're viewing
the same content
so there's this synchronization so two
individuals brains
look very much alike while they're
watching the same content well over time
researchers have adopted this to a
identify
how are different content types treated
so i did some work uh
back in 2012 with john height trying to
understand positive emotions which are
hard to elicit in the brain
uh using basically oprah videos to show
how people represent sort of these
positive regarded feelings for others
and now it's becoming an interesting
tool for uh researchers looking at kids
essentially what you get is is you get a
voxel time course from each
uh from each voxel so you get a time
course of activity from each voxel if
someone's watching a video
i'm not going to show you this video
right now this is from the finding nemo
you have consistent across viewers you
have idiosyncratic or you have
spontaneous
so you have three different types of
signal really when it comes down to it
you have those that are very similar
across viewers
you have some that are just sort of
spontaneous noise fluctuations
and you have some that are idiosyncratic
meaning that they're kind of reliable
but they're just
their own sort of subjects viewing of
that video just their own sort of
response from that area
um what kantlon and others did is they
did this in children
and they did this both in kids and
adults and what they were interested in
is the maturity
of the cortex itself over time to these
video types and what they had is
kids watching sesame street and they
created
these maps that they called neural
maturity maps
and what they could do is they could go
children to adults they could say
here's where adults are congruent to one
another here's where
children are congruent to other children
and here's where children and adults are
the same and here's where children and
adults are different
so you could have this and you just
simply line up subject from one to
subject all the way down
subject one to all the way down and then
you can compare
sort of where the spaces are that
children and adults are maximally
different
and then you can use this as a map of
neural maturity
and they did and they were able to come
up with this metric this neural maturity
correlation
and then they were actually able to then
look within a single area this is
broca's area
and determine whether or not this
material
neural maturity index maps onto a
behavior
so in this case a language type of
behavior in children which is changing
during this time
and they had great success doing this so
we've been doing a similar technique
with our studies with our kids we have
them in the magnet
we have them at rest this is from an
older slide here
showing uh children watching inscapes
and you run the inter intersubject
synchronization analysis
the inner subject correlation analysis
whatever you want to call it in this
case
you have uh 23 of the voxels are
correlated
and it's all coming back from these
occipital areas again as i told you
there's these sort of moving things on
the screen you are activating
the visual system in a synchronized way
because they're looking at the same
visual content
you have this nemo control 42 of the
voxels
are correlated so a little bit more of
the brain again you're getting more
content area more cognitive type of area
they're processing what's going on in
the scene
in this nemo social condition this is a
condition where
the fish are working together uh to
escape the darla
the the fish killer in the dentist
office for those that have seen nemo
and in this case you're bringing in even
more uh recruitment of the brain
because it's it's more rich social
content compared to this control video
itself
um so again we we did the same sort of
procedure that uh katlin and others did
you find the inner subject
synchronization
we do the correlation matrix um we've
tested this with
mentalizing capabilities we've tested
this within the mentalizing rois
themselves so just taking areas
uh from the neurosynthetic online
database
and just looking at certain voxels that
the field have described as being
involved in mentalizing processes
um and then doing this this analysis
between children and adults
uh to determine whether or not we can
get a neural maturity index
in this case we're just using older kids
and younger kids
just to show you really quick one of the
highlights of what i think we're getting
out of this which i think is interesting
and some of this has changed as we
collected more kids and we're kind of in
the middle of doing
a lot of this amalia has also given the
parents this ssis
which is a social skills improvement
scale
which measures problem behaviors and
social skills
and it's a parental report in that case
results from this are really intriguing
what you get
is when you look at social skills and
you look at average isc values
to all other children and females in
particular
you see a strong correlation
in such that those that um score higher
on the social skills
look more adult-like so they look like
the more the average of the
of the older kids than those that score
lower
so instead of using age as a predictor
of change over time you're actually
using skill as a predictor of age over
time
on the other hand uh this is a the ssis
asd score so problems uh behavior so
social skill
in terms of being a detriment again you
see less problems overall
with higher uh levels of um
i'm sorry better synchronization with
lower scores on this which mean
better social behaviors and again uh
here uh with self-control better
self-control
with more of this mature brain response
than emo and
uh the better brain response to nemo you
get uh
less externalizing behavior so again
this is a nice native correlation in
that case
um so again this in what we think we
found here is as a way
of instead of just looking at
differences that are a result of
age uh we've actually been able to find
a
unique individual subject measure that's
pulling out
differences in phenotype of the kids
so whether that's a social
characteristic as reported by parents
or whether that's something we can
measure in the lab and to the degree to
which we can optimize this and do this
better
we can learn more about functional
systems supporting these behaviors
we can leverage this variability to
understand the development of those
areas to understand how those areas
support various behaviors
and to understand how those areas are
involved in deficit
and what are kinds of biological genetic
et cetera and other factors that might
influence that as well so that's what
our ultimate goals are in that case
i'm going to go ahead and um uh uh open
up to questions because i'm weary of
time it's uh
it's nine minutes to the hour so i'll
let jack go ahead and uh start in on
some questions now
jamie thank you so much for sharing your
work with us on individual difference
this is fascinating
stuff it's such a rich area you can see
why you're so interested in it
a couple of questions from me
um the fusiform face area has been very
famous or infamous depending on who you
talk to
um and there's been a lot of work in
looking at obviously
faces versus other stuff because faces
are sort of special
um that we believe but there's also been
studies which have shown that like
there's
almost like expertise elements to the
fusiform ferrous area
so for example people who are really
interested in in
birds or antique collectible items or
flowers or cars or something
can often activate the fusiform face
area and it's giving rise to the notion
of
sort of an object topi of that area of
the inferior temporal lobe
i'm curious about um your thoughts on
individual differences there
is in contrast to faces with say other
objects
in particular like the work of uh isabel
gauthier
um on some of her work on training
people and stuff
you're very familiar with that i'm sure
yeah i mean so one thing that's
that's very characteristic of humans is
that we are
uh first of all we are very uh plastic
neurobiologically which allows us to
learn new skills with all new
new hobbies something like let's take
like a bird watcher for example you can
go
from knowing nothing about birds and if
you're passionate about becoming a bird
watcher
you can you know in a number of years
distance between 600 bird types probably
uh you know you have these big brilliant
brains that can develop hobbies and
expertise for various areas
now to the degree to which visual
specialization takes
takes part and how that plays a role
in these plastic capabilities and skills
is a question that has come up in the
face perception world
uh such that are we just
good at faces because we're expert at
pieces are are
we active in the fusiform do we show
this response because faces are just a
common area of expertise amongst the
whole population as i said before
faces are important to us there's
something that we develop over time
there's something that we get really
good at
there are arguments all the way into the
womb about the degree to which
babies that are in the womb you know
shining lights into there can
can uh depict and differentiate between
face like stimuli
how early this develops critical periods
that it won't develop
and expertise for objects that does not
follow that
and their arguments back and forth i'm
not going to take a strong stance on
that today
except for to say that it's possible
because
neither one of those activation types
can necessarily explain how good the
behavior is in either way
then maybe this is again a case where
the connectome can help us solve that
can we find differences for the degree
to which face recognition
itself can be explained by functional
connectivity differences
and how does this map on to expertise
and one natural way we could do this
is we could test the connectome with
people that aren't experts in something
we can make them go become experts in
something and then we can see if we can
spot any of the connectome changes
and whether or not those share some of
those positive edges
with base recognition that would be a
super cool experiment
it's an experiment that was done with
glm and blobs
and on the fusiform uh but maybe there's
time for a modern update of that and
that might actually settle some of the
critique
um other than that you know it's an
interesting debate
um uh it's uh i'm i'm not gonna go too
much further down that road of that
except for it to say
i think that's another thing that data
science could lend some
answer to in a empirical way
how might one quantify the degree of
memorability of faces or other objects
in
a way you know that one might try to do
this kind of experiment
in the sense that you know the person
who last served you starbucks
has a face but you probably don't
remember what it was but on the other
hand
madison avenue seems to have figured out
that face memorability
can be linked to you know products we
might like to buy
and so there must be something about
that is that something we can quantify
something that we how is that done that
might help us with some of that
uniformity
that would allow us to make people
experts in things do you know what i
mean
yeah certainly there's some argument uh
of that and i mean
so everything about face recognition is
interesting and because
you mentioned that that way is is that
outside of neuroscience it's a super
interesting question in terms of ai and
technology i mean yeah
you know obviously at some point in time
i mean uh apple
uh must have invested you know uh some
very very large sum of money so that we
could always
unlock themselves right yeah you know so
least recognition is a problem that
that goes across many disciplines and
and
yes as you said i'm sure madison avenue
has been interested in this for years
what's a memorable face
in terms of ways that people have done
it in psychology
you could do it in a single session how
good are people that look at
faces that are computer generated so
there's no chance they've ever saw them
before
and then recognize them 20 minutes later
that's one way that's a short sort of
recognition
timeline so is there differences there
and are those meaningful for something
then you have famous face tests you know
so people
born in a certain year should have some
x number of faces they would recognize
because you can have
culturally relevant faces in there and
those will differ based off of how old
you are
is there a metric there and there is and
you know and then there's arguments
about
okay is that longer term famous space
different than the shorter term face
recognition task i did
and you know the ultimate solution to
that is is that
it really looks like there's some stable
differences in both of those types of
of uh experiments
um but they're dependent upon people's
experience with faces
um they're likely dependent upon the
person's genetics and capabilities that
they're coming along with as i mentioned
from some of those data from
the twin studies uh but it's a
consideration
you know and it's a consideration when
you test these things off what is it
that you're interested in things that
people have encountered in the past or
people encounter
um in the present or people making these
sort of quick
judgments and like i saw this person
yesterday and it seems like it's tapping
into a common framework
but there are subtle differences likely
first
this leads me to that in some of your
nemo tasks and some of the other tasks
you
described for us today you discuss
things like the
exploratory graph analysis the use of
support vector machines and some other
types of machine learning type things
that are now becoming just so popular
what other kind of data science related
computational methods are you interested
in seeing for the work that you're doing
well yeah
i'm i'm really interested in two things
and and
it sort of colored a lot of what we've
been doing lately one
i am interested in things like hudson's
exploratory graph analysis and other
researchers that have done things like
this because
this is i think is a huge role of data
science
in diagnostics so we do things like for
instance
tim salt house who was an authority on
aging research at the university of
virginia
uh has published some of the most
relevant work in that over time
what he would do is for years he would
take these people from the community
and he would give them hours and hours
of cognitive tests
bring them in bring them in three times
in the summer you know do a total of
like nine hours of tests
just an awful lot of testing so that he
could create very stable
uh latent variables of of
processing speed intelligence verbal
ability cognitive capability
etc um there's a premium though there's
a problem with that one is is that
for special populations they might not
come in for nine hours
right so especially aging population
things like that we need to get quicker
so we need to be able to have
better factor analysis type of
procedures
ways that we can reduce where are we
getting the maximal amount of variance
that distinguishes people
and tucks into the psychological process
that we're interested in
and that's where something like ega
comes in uh some of the other procedures
that people do
super interested in that for autism it's
again it's one of these diagnostic tools
where it's not like there's a yes or no
you know my child has a deficit here or
doesn't you know it's it's really tested
amongst a lot a lot of cascada factors
can we find the core factors and reduce
them
to better diagnostic procedures so
that's one
and that would help with individual
subject differences at the brain level
the brain the part that i'm most
interested in
is this observation as i mentioned the
thin
paper that was the thing that got me
most excited about this years ago
was that there is some stable variation
in the connectome which is really cool
because if there's state if again if if
you know nothing else about research
methods going into anything
uh is you know the one thing that always
comes out is is that
you know in order to to pick up anything
that's a meaningful individual
difference you need reliability
and you need to test three test
reliability bold
glm imaging isn't great for this it's
it's reasonable for some tasks
particularly easier tasks
but it's not terrific but if the
connectome
has some level of stability that we can
and is variable
and that variability can explain
cognitive and social
capabilities then that gives us a real
chance
now the problem there is is that
connecto models
of attention connecto models of face
recognition
generally if we do this 268 by 268
matrix which is just one that we use
because that's one that they've used
before
you know that's 17 000 comparisons we're
making
and the model fit will often pull out
1020 connections edges that
are needed to predict that model what's
that tell you about the brain that's a
whole lot of connection so
so it tells you that the brain is a
highly connected
universe that is involved in this
complex behavior but we want to get
further down we want to get more
granular so you need more techniques in
that case
um as you know jack one of the uh
professors starting in our department
and in data science in in the fall is
teak henry
and he's involved in a lot of of uh
trying to find local differences within
network science
that can help us reduce this problem
well with that uh jamie morris thank you
so much for
sharing your work on individual
differences with us today um
fascinating work such a rich area so
many different things to try
uh across you know not only in
developing children but across the
lifespan
just fascinating stuff thank you again
thank you everybody who joined us today
um have a great weekend we will not be
having a data science seminar
next friday next friday we're taking a
little bit of a spring break
so giving everybody a week off but we
will see you the week after
thank you so much everybody enjoy your
time see you later